I WANT TO TURN TO SOME IMPORTANT
NEW REPORTING TH HOUR ON A
TURF WAR OVER WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
FIND SOME VERY IMPORTANT MSING
TEXT MESSAGES.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL INSTRUCTING
THE SECRET SERVICE TO STOP ITS
INTERNAL INCREASING WHY JANUARY
6th-RELATED TEXT MESSAGES WERE
DELETED.
LET'S GET THE LATEST FROM CNN'S
WHITNEY WILD.
WHITNEY, WHAT IS THIS ABOUT AND
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT?
>> THE SECRET SERVICE RECEIVED A
NOTICE WEDNESDAY TELLING THE
SECRET SERVICE TO STOP
INVESTIGATING THE MATTER,
BECAUSE IT COULD INTERFERE WITH
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OWN
INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE AGENCY'S TEXT MESSAGES.
THIS WEDNESDAY LETTER COMING
FROM THE IG, TELLING SECRET
SERVICE, IN EFFECT, STAND DOWN
FOR NOW.
THE LETTER ADDS TO THIS GROWING
SECRET SERVICE 2000 THE SECRET
SERVICE AND THE DHS INSPECTOR
GENERAL OVER THESE MISSING TEXT
MESSAGES, WHICH ARE ALSO BEING
SOUGHT BY THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE AS PART OF ITS
INVESTIGATION INTO FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP'S ACTIONS
AND MOVEMENTS ON JANUARY 6th,
2021.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM THIS LETTER.
TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
INVESTIGATION, THE USSS MUST NOT
ENGAGE IN ANY FURTHER
INVESTIGATIVE ACTIVITIES
REGARDING THE COLLECTION AND
PRESERVATION OF THE EVIDENCE
REFERENCED ABOVE.
THIS INCLUDES IMMEDIATELY
REFRAINING FROM INTERVIEWING
POTENTIAL WITNESSES, COLLECTING
DEVICES, OR TAKING ANY OTHER
ACTION THAT WOULD INTERFERE WITH
AN ONGOING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
JOHN, WE KNOW THAT THE IG HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO EVENTUALLY
REFER THINGS FOR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
SECRET SERVICE HAS ALREADY BEGUN
WHAT THEY CALL A VERY RIGOROUS
EVENT INTO WHAT HAPPENED TO
THESE POTENTIALLY MISSING TEXT
MESSAGES AND WHY.
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE
SUBPOENAED BY THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
THEY'VE TOLD THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE THEY'RE CONDUCTING
FORENSIC EXAMINATIONS.
THEY'RE DOING INTERVIEWS TO TRY
TO ABIDE BY THAT DIRECTIVE.
THIS IS MAKING THINGS SO MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED FOR THE SECRET
SERVICE AS IT TRIES TO ABIDE BY
THESE OVERSIGHT BODIES.
>> AT ODDS WITH ONE ANOTHER TO
SAY THE LEAST.
APPRECIATE THAT IMPORTANT
REPORTING.
JOINING US NOW, CNN LEGAL
ANALYST, GARY CORDERO AND THE
FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, ANDY McCABE.
YOU WORKED AT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
THAT, YES, SOMETIMES HAS TO
UPDATE THE PHONES.
SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIONS.
THERE TO BE CAREFUL PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE.
WHAT IN THE WORLD WENT WRONG
HERE?
>> REALLY GREAT QUESTION, JOHN.
I HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS PROCESS
FROM EVERY LEVEL FROM MY TIME IN
THE FBI.
AS AN AGENT AND A SENIOR LEADER
OVERSEEING SOME EXCHANGES,
TECHNOLOGICAL EXCHANGES.
I'VE NEVER, EVER SEEN A PROCESS
THAT INVOLVED EVERY INDIVIDUAL
AGENT OR USER OF A PHONE PUTTING
THE RESPONSIBILITY ON THEM
INDIVIDUALLY TO PRESERVE THEIR
OWN DATA.
IT'S INEXPLICABLE TO ME.
>> INEXPLICABLE, AND WE'LL SEE
HOW IT GETS SORTED OUT, AND IF
WE'LL GET ANY OF THE MESSAGES.
AS PART OF THIS, WE HAVE THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS DHS INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION INTO JANUARY 6th,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES SAID YESTERDAY
TWICE NO PERSON IS ABOVE THE LAW
IN THIS COUNTRY, NOTHING STOPS
US, IN THE CONTEXT OF, CAN YOU
INVESTIGATE DONALD TRUMP.
NO PERSON ABOVE THE LAW IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I CAN'T SAY IT MORE CLEARLY THAN
THAT.
DID MERRICK GARLAND JUST HAVE TO
SAY THAT PUBLICLY OR IS THERE A
MESSAGE IN THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S ABOUT WHAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, AND REALLY, WE
SHOULDN'T EXPECT MUCH MORE.
BECAUSE IF WE WANT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABIDING BY THE
TRADITIONAL NORMS OF NOT
COMMENTING ON ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS, NOT CASTING
ASPERSIONS ON PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIMES, AND ALLOWING THEM TO
CONDUCT THE INVESTIGATION THAT
THEY HAVE, THEN, REALLY, WE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT MUCH
MORE FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SO I THINK THAT IS ABOUT AS
BLAND A STATEMENT AS WE COULD
HEAR FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
BUT, FRANKLY, I DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD BE SAYING MUCH MORE ABOUT
IT.
>> WELL, THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN TRYING TO
LEAD THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO THE
WATER, IF YOU WILL, THROUGH ITS
TESTIMONY IN ITS PUBLIC
HEARINGS.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DAMNING
TESTIMONY.
THE LEGAL EXPERT WHO IS LOOK AT
THIS SAY, THEY SEE FOUR
POTENTIAL CRIMES FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
OBSTRUCTION OF A OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION, SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY,
WITNESS TAMPERING.
TONIGHT, A PRIME-TIME HEARING
ABOUT THAT 187 MINUTES OF WHAT
DONALD TRUMP DID.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT HE
REFUSED TO DO DURING THAT.
IS THAT PROVING DERELICTION OF
DUTY OR DO YOU THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TONIGHT WITH THESE
WHITE HOUSE INSIDERS TO HELP
PROVE, IS THAT A CRIME,
DERELICTION OF DUTY IS
DERELICTION OF DECENCY.
BUT WHAT ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIMES?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO STEP BACK
FROM THE CRIME CLIFF, AS IT
WERE.
AND REMEMBER, WHAT IS THE
COMMITTEE TRYING TO DO?
THE COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO
PRESENT A COMPELLING AND
COMPLETE, AUTHOR RTHOROUGH NARR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND ALL THE BAD THINGS
THAT DONALD TRUMP DID.
ONE OF THE BAD THINGS IS
COMPLETELY OBLITERATING AND
IGNORING HIS OATH TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION, TO
ENSURE THAT THE LAWS ARE
FAITHFULLY EXECUTED.
AND HE DID THAT BY -- AS WE'LL
SEE TONIGHT -- TWITTERING AWAY,
WATCHING TELEVISION, AND DOING
NOTHING TO STOP THE ATTACK ON
THE NATION'S CAPITOL.
>> YEAH, I THINK TONIGHT IS LESS
ABOUT THE COMMITTEE LAYING OUT
POTENTIAL EVIDENCE FOR CRIMINAL
CULLABILITY THAN IT IS ABOUT
POTENTIALLY HAVING POLITICAL
ARGUMENTS IN THE FUTURE TO
PREVENT HIM FROM RECEIVING A
NOMINATION OR ASSUMING PUBLIC
OFFICE EVER AGAIN.
THE DERELICTION OF DUTY IS
REALLY WAS THE SUBJECT OF THE
SECOND IMPEACHMENT.
IT IS ABOUT HIS INACTION AND THE
THINGS THAT HE DIDN'T DO TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY, TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY OF LAWMAKERS, AND TO
PROTECT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL WHO WERE AT THE
CAPITOL SITE THAT DAY.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S THE SAME
CONVERSATION AS POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL --
>> AND THE COMMITTEE PROMISES
SOME NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT.
THEY HAVE DELIVERED ON THOSE
PROMISES IN THE PAST.
WE WILL SEE IF WE GET IT TONIGHT
AS WELL.